I'd like to moderate these things
because I'm not you know I think they
knew that too coming in that I wouldn't
be a good person to speak at this
necessarily but a good moderator I can
ask a couple questions so thanks for
having us just want to go through and
introduce everyone and not fall off the
stage so starting to man to my right
Tommy Tong it's that faint world-famous
street style photographer round of
applause if you don't know him
if you don't know maybe you're in the
wrong room we all know him we all know
his work really well in it and maybe if
you haven't seen him met him in person
you've seen his work online and Tommy
thanks for being here yes thank you for
having me this site also jack-and-jill
which is true where it all started the
man to his right Nick Worcester who I
gloriously hails from camp Salina Kansas
almost as great as Cleveland Ohio which
is where I'm from
now right but Nicholas are just a quick
story about Nick and now I give him the
full introduction but we were in
Florence last year and a guy came up to
Nick on the street and said I really
admire your style and that was kind of
the first first thing I first time I've
ever heard anyone say just someone I
just admire the way you dress and it was
it was a pivotal amazing moment but Nick
Boozer has sort of worked in every
capacity in the menswear world from
buyer creative director fashion director
for some of the best stores some of the
biggest brands you've done
collaborations you're a tumbler icon
Nick Boosh there's the man so and he's
super humble and we're gonna try to get
through some of his humbleness to
actually talking and and not be so not
be so humbled today but thanks for being
here Nick thank you
and Manta is right Shawn Sullivan also a
tumblr icon basically started a site
called the impossible cool five years
ago I think I was there a few moments
after it started and we've become
friends and so Shawn through just the
impossible cool has you know sort of
pursued his love of photography his
interest in fashion and has become this
you know what we're here to talk about
today you know has become a menswear
influencer certainly you you sort of
embody all of that for better or worse
right but so Shawn Sullivan from the
impossible cool thanks for being here
thank you I think for better for better
and you know adding some the female
touch the girl next door
menswear girl next door is is how the
details folks were describing you but
Megan Collins from the style girlfriend
thank you for being here
next up is Lawrence Schlossman who
currently works her for fins as the
editor-in-chief I learned this morning
his exact title but he wrote the book
[ __ ] yemen's where and he basically they
say they D does describe you as the
voice of menswear online hashtag
menswear cuz it's less important that
way thank you
so the voice of hashtag menswear the
always ever-present always around
non-stop Laurens awesome and we're gonna
let not let him talk until the last five
minutes because once he starts talking
you one stop yeah thanks one black hole
of attention and Eugene Tong from
details is also sitting in to ask a
couple questions to provide some insight
and to be the most stylish guy and I
need some people so they let me up yeah
he knows somebody okay so just to give
the introduction side of the way Dan
thank you for having us
details thanks for putting this together
let's just jump right into it we're here
to talk about sort of how how do you go
beyond the blog how do you and not in
all situations it's not ever
here doesn't necessarily have a very
defined blog but how do you take you
know your interest and your presence
online and how is that evolved for
brands and how does how is that become
you know a way to promote yourself a way
to work with brands and to make money
Tommy it seems a little bit we're just
looking to you first you you go you come
at this from a photography standpoint
more directly and so that would mean you
have an agent which they're not you do
how is that impacted your relationship
with brands and how is that affected
sort of you monetizing what you do
having an agent completely changed I
mean everything hi Ally she's here
you know before having an agent you know
I had idea in my mind of what I wanted
to do but once you have an agent
basically they can just clarify your
vision in how you want to steer the ship
so basically you know not to raise your
standards but it makes you realize you
know what you want to do with your
career and what path you want to follow
so it's all about strategy and what path
you want to take and as it has it helped
you monetize what you're doing as it
helps you focus more in the creativity I
mean what are the benefits of that sort
of relationship I wouldn't be lying if I
didn't say that having agent helped
monetize what I did and you know I had
some relationships with some clients but
then having an agent just makes things
so much more obviously professional on
my part because I don't have to deal
with the clients you know like I do
obviously but having someone that go
sheets on your behalf just makes things
a lot easier because you know not having
an experience beforehand at all you know
I just didn't have an understanding of
what I did or what I wanted to achieve
so you know it's not necessarily all
about making money either it's just
about sort of pursuing your creative
yeah absolutely you definitely need to
have someone that has your best
interests at heart and you definitely
want to do things that make you feel
happy and you know you do get your hands
dirty at times and you do do those jobs
but I mean you know at the end of day
it's it's a it's me doing something I'm
passionate
but it is a job so yeah Shawn what's
your interaction with you know you you
you basically started your site
impossible cool you know your posting
you know all these iconic pictures you
know I think in another life you could
have been a really talented photo editor
you know you're you you're sort of you
gained all this notoriety just from
doing this online and then all these
opportunities gave me you how did you
know how did you deal with that
um I think when you were involved in the
beginning stuff with hmm some of the
video stuff in the beginning it was very
much kind of there was this window open
where we had this visibility all of a
sudden and I looked at it as a way to
kind of take that middleman which an
agent or an agency or something like
that I looked at that as an opportunity
to cut them out and do it all on my own
so sometimes it was you and me pitching
projects and I think that that was very
good and it worked in its infancy but
you get to a certain point like what
Tommy's gotten or any of any other of us
where you actually need that middle
marine you need that middle person
because you get to negotiations that you
don't understand you get to contracts
that are five pages long all that sort
of stuff so I think I I never wanted to
rush getting an agent because I was one
that's kind of like be able to build
this stuff on my own but you definitely
get to a certain point of where you need
someone after a while did you think that
did you I mean taking a step back did
you ever think that it would come to the
point where branch would because you
created a presence online and became
known I mean I think that's the
obviously the value for this you were so
short answer yeah yeah yeah I mean I
knew that at some point that we get to I
mean because it wasn't when all this
stuff started happening the kind of all
started getting names when you accept
that it's not going anywhere
that you know it it's not the internet
isn't gonna go anywhere just gonna keep
going and going and building and
building
I knew that there would be a certain
point where I get to that point of
needing an agent but in the beginning it
was fun to like try it out on my own and
see where it went
Megan what are your thoughts and and any
of you guys can jump in on this or if
you have thoughts or whatever but Megan
what do you what do you think I mean how
what's your relationship been with
working with brands and um maybe
different than these guys it feels very
personal to work with a brand and
I'm worth this and I think as a woman
for pet her for worse I think it's
really hard to stick to that and to you
know not back down or just to learn to
negotiate and not take it so personally
but when you are your brand I think that
that's you know it's inevitably pretty
intertwined so yeah I think having
someone to be able to do that for you is
really helpful I also think I hate the
idea you know selling out or that what
we do because it's what we're passionate
about we shouldn't you know selling it
with money or something like that I mean
I never understood the notion of
stopping liking your favorite band when
they got in the radio right like that
doesn't make any sense to me shouldn't
you be happy that they're doing well and
that more people know about them now so
I think something for me about
monetizing the blog is just the idea
that you shouldn't be made to feel like
you're selling out I think you should be
happy that you get to do what you love
all the time I think a lot of people
don't necessarily understand to what
goes into you know doing a site like
yours or to you know creating a site how
much time and effort and energy goes
into it and I think you know it's
changing that perception of you know the
value certain people are getting when
something's free they think it should
just be free and no one should ever have
to pay for it and then it's hard to put
a price on something someone got one
says that was freeing Lauren Sam oh I
think your mic is orange what are your
thoughts I mean how you you know you
very quickly went from doing this
anonymous tumblr [ __ ] mint where to
getting a book to you I mean was that
something was that surprising how that
happened well it was absolutely
surprising I mean it was never a goal
that was something that myself and my
co-author and friend Kevin we did just
cuz it was hilarious to us we didn't
like make this site to get a book deal
or to try to get an agent it's one of
those things that kind of happened
organically which at least for me I mean
I don't know if anyone you know on this
panel like the first step is oh well I'm
gonna be success for them to make money
I think the first thing like Megan is
saying is you find something you're
passionate about and you pursue that for
the joy that's in it and
assuming it's something you truly are at
the end of a passionate about the the
fruits of your Labor's they will come to
will come to fruition and that's what
happened it happened with the book it
was just a sight that we did whether or
not honestly or not was just for us and
it kind of blew up which is not
something we intended but the book and
and some of the stuff that came from it
that was never the from the get-go there
was nothing we wanted to sound like
without that we weren't gonna do it you
know I think it's yeah I think Lawrence
is a really good example of someone that
was really interested in the you know
menswear as a business or as a industry
or as a job and that's sort of and you
took that interest and I remember you
were when you started your site
originally you were you know you're
living in Charlotte yeah yeah I think
there's a lot of bloggers who start
blogs with the goal of becoming like a
professional blogger it's a planet-sized
their personal brand to use buzzwords
but for me I always used my personal
sites which I've never monetized like
with ads or anything because you chose
not to or because you're not gonna again
wanted to advertise no it would just be
honest oh yeah no no but if for me it
was always um you know my interest in
menswear and my passion it was always
something that I wanted to do
professionally and there's an Grant that
there's nothing wrong with wanting to to
monetize your personal brand to work for
yourself I mean that's fantastic a lot
of people up here do just that but for
me what I wanted was to take a route I
think that less people think about was
do my thing do it well because I love it
and then you can turn that into a
nine-to-five that doesn't [ __ ] suck
right like you can have a job that
you're excited to go to and that's kind
of what I've been doing for the past you
know three years is taking kind of the
whatever personal recognition is out
there from whatever site that I was
running be it you know [ __ ] menswear
or something else and then turning that
into a kind of like an actual job and
building a career from that well I think
a lot of people if you look at a lot of
sites too a lot of sites sort of go
through this process of growing and
becoming well-known and a lot of people
and then and that's always a means to an
end so that's always you know them
trying to get a job at four pins or them
you know trying to get a job at details
magazine and so a lot of sites follow
this arc where they'll grow and then
they become known and then they go off
and do what they sort of originally
intended and then there's other people
that do this basically as you know like
in my situation I always just wanted to
do my site I didn't want to get a job
anywhere else and and I think that that
sort of provided me a certain degree of
like longevity just based on the fact
I'm not trying to go somewhere else and
I think you know everyone here has been
successful I really just you know
following through on that and that's you
know I think that's something people can
really look at and say you know if I if
I really want to build a blog you have
to be committed to doing it and and just
stick with it and keep doing it I mean
Nick this I mean we have to just ask
doesn't apply to me because I'm like the
fraud up here I mean I am the what the
fraud when they you know when they said
you know beyond the blog and monetizing
I'm like wait a minute I didn't even get
involved in that I mean I would love to
figure out how to do that so I was here
to take notes
he's sitting in the wrong section I
really am in the wrong section know
you've monetized it you've done all
these you've done all these partnerships
and collaborations you've done you've
consulted for brands I mean all of that
is that's the sort of unseen side of
monetizing a blog or monetizing your you
know your influencer status is working
sort of behind the scenes working on
projects maybe you know that people knew
or were product collaborations can you
talk about some of that stuff yeah and I
mean you know it's a hundred percent the
result of social media and the internet
I'm waiting to get fired from the
internet like I do every other company I
work for I was gonna yeah when we were
when we were going over when we were
going over Nick's introduction I was
saying you've been fired by some of the
most prestigious and you know businesses
in menswear so anyway I you know listen
I am super grateful and it is it's
really a hundred percent sort of this
that I mean I'm even sitting here
because I was always the same guy that I
was before I always dressed a little bit
funny and you know and it's because of
people like Laurence and Tommy
especially at the beginning who you know
took my picture and like holy [ __ ] how
did that
happen you know I just got dressed I
mean that's really how I view the whole
thing but I have worked in the business
a long time and and I'm now at the stage
where I've got to figure out what that
next thing is but it is I guess because
I haven't really done anything in terms
of putting my foot in the air you know
drawing a line in the sand you know I'm
opinionated I'd love to say things but I
really haven't done that because the
minute I do I recognize that it's gonna
alienate a lot of people or you know
it's all been organic and so in that way
I'm super grateful to the internet and
to everyone sort of here because it's
really been super fun like I've worked
in this business since I was 15 years
old or have you at least worked in
retail since I was 15 years old so I've
been around clothes all my life and
that's really what it's about so I don't
know that may be the question but well
if you look at social media and social
media had such a big you know quite a
big role and you're just becoming an
influencer becoming so well known you
know that's what inspires people on the
streets of Florence to come up to you
and say I love your style you know that
really happened but you took to the you
took to that really well you know I
think like you you you understood and
how to use tumblr and how to use social
media and you know to you know gain this
really big following well it's an
amazing forum you know and I think that
that's what it's given is everyone has a
voice or a way to do something I mean
you know 30 years ago when I moved to
New York if you were a guy or a person
and you wanted to get pictures published
I mean you had to go work for a magazine
or maybe you know write a book it's
completely different today so in that
way it's it's really amazing that
everybody can have a voice and so I just
feel grateful to be one of the many
Tommy uh just going back to you for a
quick you know when you started this
when you started you know going out
taking pictures on the street I mean
what's your goal to become a famous
photographer was it to start a blog and
make money just by doing that I mean I
was just trying to crush the show's idea
I mean I was just stocking these guys
you know like I just really wanted to do
for fun you know like I didn't have any
money I saved up to all I could and
thankfully I had a boss that sent me to
Europe as a bonus and it was just having
fun and I think if you continue to have
that mindset where you just want to
enjoy what you're doing then it doesn't
feel like a job and there was never any
intention of making money on [ __ ] it
want to make money but and be able to
afford the clothes that I want to buy
but it's it's just all good pleasure you
know just you have to focus on what it
is that you really want to do and all I
wanted to do is just take pictures so I
was just lucky the outcome of being a
photographer came out I still don't even
know how to use the cameras do you do
you want to become I mean do you want to
do something more than what you're doing
are you really happy with doing you know
doing the site and contributing where
you're doing all those other projects
I'm just really happy to be working in
fashion because it's something I always
wanted as a teenager and this is nothing
I'd ever anticipated meeting these
people and just to be able to stalk him
is just like a huge huge you know luxury
oyster I told you he's so humble Megan
when you started when you started your
site was the idea to make it a journal
living just doing that what was your
goal when you started I actually started
the diol girlfriend as a column for a
friend out in California who is starting
a men's clothing business I was working
in advertising at the time and I didn't
want to anymore so I was taking
freelance projects on the side here and
there and honestly that's just the one
that sort of stuck and really resonated
with people so it went from being a
column on his site to being syndicated
by newspapers to me searching is Dallin
girlfriend calm but no great let's let's
do this so I just screw the the content
from there and yeah I was able to you
know get out of advertising and then
gradually stop doing other freelance
projects and just focus on style
girlfriend um no it didn't make any
money at first
um at all and that's why I was doing the
other freelance projects I was you know
just kind of cobbling together a
freelance lifestyle which I think a lot
of writers can relate to and what I
found was that guys really there was a
lot of guys out there that wanted to
hear about how to dress better from a
pretty girl um you know obviously
speaking had heteronormative Lee up it
there's a lot of straight guys out there
that don't live in New York that don't
follow the hashtag menswear scene that
you know I'm their end target not me
about women and so to be able to provide
that voice and that source of
encouragement and a really sincere
really you know non Maggie kind of way
and so it's not oh my gosh would you you
know get rid of that old frat t-shirt
already it's oh man wouldn't you look
handsome if you were this that or the
other and it just resonated with a lot
of guys were you naturally just
interested in menswear or how did that
how did that idea like sort of come as
the as an angle to you know I feel like
such a fake sometimes because you know
when I friend first approached me and
said you know do you want to write this
I know you're looking to sort of
increase your byline do you want to
write a column for me an I said well I
don't know anything about guys style and
he said well just just write about what
you like to see guys wearing and I think
if you you know any girl in this
audience turn to the guy to her left she
would find that she has about ten things
to say about what he's wearing and so it
actually worked out really well because
I was able to just come at it from the
point of view of being a fan of guys
looking great you know I I kind of just
consider myself you know the ultimate
wing woman like I'm just there because
I'm wanting that guy to like succeed I
want him to get the girl at the end of
the bar or you know really knocked out
of park on that first date outfit
whatever it is so I think it's
interesting uh Lawrence I think I was
reading in the newspaper that makes me
sound old but I was reading in the neck
door the only thing that can make you
sound older than saying something like
that is saying I was on the crosstown
bus the other day
and I met this very nice gentleman
I was really reading the newspaper and
this kid said that his eat what he
wanted to do there's this article about
this guy and error this young this young
man and what he wanted to do for a
living was become a sports blogger that
was his dream job he was an art he could
just do it right there he didn't have to
I mean what do you think I mean you're
the closest Connection we have to like
the kids these days thank you so what do
you think what I mean what do you think
that well how does that put us and like
how should we think about the world you
know based on that based on just that
this is gonna get super deep well I
don't know I think it depends first of
all that kid needs higher aspirations
his parents are gonna be so disappointed
him I mean have you seen Johnny's sports
blog yeah it's really great dot blog
spot.com yeah I don't know um I mean
anyone can be a blogger I think that's
obvious
I think my I think the ask the
aspirations that some of the younger
guys on internet have I think there's I
think there's some some people are
missing the point and by some I think I
mean many as kind of style blogging
specifically about men's clothing has
become you know a thing enough that we
can have this panel today and the
exposure has increased and you know cool
things kind of come out of it like
speaking on panels and free products
getting seeded out to people such as
yourself I think that is kind of blinded
some of the younger guys who are hopping
on tumblr tomorrow and starting a blog
like starting it for the wrong
intentions and I think that comes with
being young and being kind of
short-sighted but yeah I think I think
that that that's the absolute wrong way
to to approach it you know I think
there's a lot more that you can do in
this industry then just be a blogger you
know talking about collaborating with
brands and pursuing personal artistic
projects like Shawn you know and a craft
like Tom yeah I think that's the thing
that's missing it's like what is your
craft right
you're just a blogger I mean what what
are you what do you actually
you know teaching yourself how to do or
are you taking photos are you making
films are you learning how product is
actually made and working with brands
like Nick and I think the idea of the
craft is kind of getting lost or just
being a writer that's a craft as well
you know I think the idea of being the
blogger it's like how much writing is
happening I mean you're one of the guys
that brought long-form kind of you know
to the forefront on the internet
actually it was substance you know more
than just 140 characters and I think
this is getting lost on a lot of younger
guys and girls that are trying to kind
of break into this world there's like no
sense of honing a craft and becoming a
professional in any sense of the word
and I think the Internet in general
blogging social media you know what
Tommy has done with his photography I
mean I think it the internet will be a
very it'll be the sort of great
equalizer it'll bring all these good
things so that to the top and it'll you
know Tommy's got the persistence and the
eye to do it you know and you keep doing
it you know the quality will rise to the
top and people will find the you know
the talented eye or the you know the
good voice or the the great style or you
know the creative vision you know I
think like people will the the internet
helps sort of bring all that to the
forefront and I think a lot of that you
know this panel here is sort of
exemplifies that in a lot of different
ways Shawn what do you think about
specifically thinking about tumblr and
thinking about these younger guys do you
think tumblr is preventing sort of the
next crop of menswear site from emerging
just because it's so easy to curate as
as opposed to sort of put input things
to create content I actually have this
hope that the next menswear super star
or whatever super star comes across
photography or style or whatever um
actually doesn't even really know how to
use tumblr it would be like amazing to
see someone come I have a friend in
London that's recording her album right
now and she's all over the internet and
she actually has no idea about any of
that and it's really refreshing because
you're not you're not a you're not kind
of watered down by everybody else's
opinions and thoughts and visuals and
all that sort of stuff you're developing
your own any
is what we were all doing in the
beginning like Nick had his own style
Tommy had his photography vision you
know I never wanted it's not that I
never wanted to but I never that was
never my end goal was to become a
blogger it was always just a tool are
you offended if people call you a
blogger it's not my choice of word but
like what is the one and I like for each
one of you guys kind of answer this
what's the one biggest misconception
that you guys can give you know for me
as an editor everyone thinks my life
just revolves around me going fashion
shows and parties and all that and so my
life is so glamorous whereas in
actuality there's only 1% of probably my
job right so what is the one thing that
you can tell these the guys were young
like what is the one thing that you
shouldn't be doing that you know or just
one piece of misconception that you guys
want to convey to these I think a big
misconception is that it's easy it's
really hard and people a lot of times
will ask me how do I and this is a
question that was sort of on on the
docket for today a little bit but how do
you take a start aside and grow it and
be make it something real I have no
answer that I have no idea
you just seriously disappointed it
rooster that's the only thing you want I
mean I can't stand and you just totally
just - this hopes and dreams stand next
to Nick Wooster that would be a good
place to start
and make sure people know who you are no
but I mean I think a lot of it takes
like the answers I give are you know you
have to be persistent you have to have a
vision and you have to do something and
do it every day and when I started my
side it was just I'm just gonna do this
as much as I can and keep doing it and
at the end of the day if I I did all
this work and I just had a diary of the
stuff that I was interested in I'd be
happy with that and I never sort of
wanted to make it anything more than
that but it's really difficult to do to
start a blog and make it successful it's
a lot of work well since I'm the oldest
person here I will sound like an old
person and you know and that is the deal
like it is work like it you know and it
doesn't matter what discipline where you
come from because really every single
person up here kind of represents every
facet of the business from retail
publishing you know the Internet
- you know art and and commerce and like
the bottom line is it doesn't matter
what your discipline is like it sucks to
be an assistant and yet that's every
single person in this table or at this
group has done just that and it doesn't
come easier overnight
I mean you know nine years ago I was
standing on the floor of Barneys
in Beverly Hills trying to sell women's
designer dresses because I was
unemployed and I needed a job you know
but so it's like that's the kind of [ __ ]
that one has to do I think in order to
succeed it doesn't matter what you're
doing you just have to keep doing it
Tommy what's here what would you say I
would say sacrifice everything sacrifice
your personal life and the fact that
you're not gonna eat and that you're
gonna be tired and you just have to work
really hard and just immerse yourself
completely in what you truly really want
to do because it's the only way I find
that those that have a point of view
will stick out because you know
everybody wants to be famous and
everybody wants to make money but you
know at the end of the day it's just
those that know how to hone their craft
and will give up everything just to have
it you know whatever happened to those
fashion kids that would just do anything
in that what role rocks down the garment
district or whatever right now everybody
just wants to just take pictures
themselves you know like not that
there's anything wrong with that but I
would just gonna jump in I would also
say I think that um you know don't
believe in the hype of the overnight
sensation I think that you know those
articles are written about like they
started their tumblr and five days later
they were you know on the cover a vogue
whatever it is and that's not true and
if it is that's not really gonna be the
path that you're probably following
anyways you know I think in terms of the
question of yeah like how do you grow
your own sins I totally get that young
bloggers want to sort of hear that that
magic answer and I know that when I was
looking for advice you know I think the
answer I got so often was you know it's
like that Seinfeld episode like so I
started a blog and yada yada yada
I have a million monthly page views and
a book deal like and you were like what
about the yada yada like what you know
what's happening in that part and you
can't really say I mean it's it's you
work hard and you show up you know you
continue to put out content that your
readers will find interesting and you
reward them by you know if they're
coming back tomorrow they want to see
new stuff and you give that to them and
and like I said you show up I think it's
I don't know if you guys would agree
it's not totally necessary to live in a
big city but I do think that it's also
really helpful you know a lot of the you
know watershed moments on my site and
the breakthrough moments have come from
you know not the slaving away till 2:00
in the morning right in the next day's
post but coming to events like this
meeting someone from a brand or from a
publication and finding a way to
collaborate so I do you think that's
important yeah I think access is a big
is a big part of it but it's not the
only part and I think people will give
you access if you work really hard and
exhibit a lot of care on your site or
you know how it goes into it
Sean Warren so you guys want to add
anything we're gonna oh we're almost
ready to do QA so I was just gonna say I
had something for a little while it's
kind of you know what we were just
talking about of the overnight sensation
stuff and you kind of get it you gotta
get in this mindset where you start and
you put your entire self into something
and you work on it for years and years
and years and it probably will go
nowhere for a couple years I was just
read I was in London last week and I
went to see this urn when Blumenfeld a
photo exhibit in London and I watch this
documentary that they were playing there
and it was the first time I ever found
this out about this photographer that he
was 44 before he had his first
photograph published ever and he had
been working his entire life on that and
it just kind of backed up for me that
you have to spend time working on
and it could take a really long time and
the thought of like starting a blog and
meeting an overnight sensation I think
for some of it some of us it was alive I
think there are a couple overnight
sensations from that world but for the
most part you just had to stick with it
you had to like I was a 49 year old
overnight sensation yeah just one I
think my last point that I make is like
we all rave about the Democratic nature
of the Internet and it's so great and
that's why a lot of us are here now but
I think people also use it as a crutch
to be very much the same as a lot of
people in their field and just be
another person on tumblr and it's it's
almost like it's a double-edged sword
like it's great that you can get out
there tomorrow but don't let that
democratic nature then like suppress
your true artistic vision or a skill set
that you have or trying to develop and
it's about combining these two things
and and and utilizing the democratic
nature for positive as opposed to just
falling in line with everyone else which
is like Jonna Singh yeah I was terrified
I was told I did tumblr wrong because I
was posting too much copy if I had more
than like two paragraphs people are like
stop just put a picture up so yeah you
have to not sort of listen to that
that's good advice and we've basically
crushed all the ambition of everyone in
the audience so we're gonna open it up
for a little Q&A before before we take
the first question my first question to
Nick was dress who makes those pants you
chug Lilly Pulitzer they're product from
two Springs ago Thanks okay questions hi
so seems like one of the messages of
this conversation is that being genuine
is really important to building a
compelling publication or blog but
there's obviously a tension between
being genuine and making money this is
something that journalists have dealt
with where they'll make a wall between
ads and editorial and and monetization
basically with blogs it's harder to do
that you can't just hire someone who's
gonna handle that so how do you deal
with helping and still trust into your
publication making it so that your
readers don't look at your site and they
see these ads and they say oh you're
you're these are influencing you how do
you how do you disclose that how do you
keep that transparent yeah I'll speak
for the editorial portion of it I mean
for us it's no secret that ads generate
the revenue for our magazine I mean
there's a reason why we put this on it's
not the edit budget that's putting this
on right it's the advertising budget I
think what
so because everyone knows that that's
the case I think the job as an editor is
to not mask that it's very obvious right
but what we would like to do is like you
know we try to satisfy both lines right
we don't count we don't we try not to
you know put our point of view behind
our advertising commitments right so
it's about finding that balance and and
as an editor like that's what we do on a
given time when I'm running through with
Dan Artur and chief you know there's
certain things that will come up that
will be needed to be shot or need to be
in book but it's about balancing all
that and still getting your point of
view across and I think as details I
mean I'm biased but I feel like we do a
very great job about that you know I
mean aim and we're not sitting here I'm
not gonna sit here and lie to you and be
like oh no we don't shoot advertisers of
course we do it's a business and you
need to make money but you know I think
it's finding that balance and I think
that's that's what makes a good editor
these days it's being able to balance
that yeah I've always from eyesight too
I've always taken the standpoint that
and I came from basically working with
magazines and sort of from the PR world
and so I sort of understood how the
details of the of the world operated and
I took that and said well I want to sort
of operate my site on under that same
principle so I wanted to be very
straightforward when something was
advertising base or sponsored and you
know and I wasn't ever trying to trick
anyone so what I would try to do is I'd
try to produce content that was on the
same voice the same level of what I
normally produce on straight editorial
and I and I do that but I call it out
very specifically as sponsored and I
think my readers responded to that as
being very fair to them and I look
around and I understand how the
magazines work and I understand how
advertising works and digital and I know
who works where and where relationships
are and I look at things on blogs and I
say this is clearly sponsored and
they're not telling anyone I know but
does anyone else know and how is that
fair to people and how does that serve
the advertiser and how does it serve the
reader you know and it's not fun for
anyone in
and it's just it's just weird and shady
yeah I think disappointing I think that
like the common thread that's going on
throughout all this is as long as you're
genuine right there as long as you're
the people that say genuine with their
audience they're the people and that can
lead to monetizing the site or could not
lead to monetizing the site but if you
keep doing good work people will respond
to it in a positive way I've noticed
that a lot of the sites on the internet
that catch hell you know jumps into the
advertising very quickly and they had to
explain it to their audience and their
audience in some way kind of went
against them for it they don't though in
the audience doesn't necessarily realize
how much time these people get into
doing it from I cited a lot of times
like the advertising money just allows
me to go and travel to create new
content you know so it's that's how it
fuels it but people don't understand
they want it to be it's just the idea of
changing the perception of something you
got for free to something you feel like
you had to pay for and people don't
necessarily like that well it's like the
case of you know your favorite band
being found out about pitchfork or
something you know you have that people
were very precious with your site people
were precious with all of our sites I
think it's some way and they feel like
some sort of ownership because they've
been looking at him for a very long time
but the way that you handled it as it
being genuine I think is the perfect way
and you don't offend your audience and
they still believe in you do we have
time for one more a couple more
what's that okay one more max max he
wants to cut us off but he feels awkward
because he's smoking okay
yellow shirt guy this all started over
telling me really quick what would be
the and we'll just go down the road make
it really simple if you had to give five
recommendations on not to put something
on your blog what would it be like for
things to not more and we'll just go
down the woods you know one two three
four five yeah to sort of help somebody
that's you know up-and-coming that would
like to sort of be in your shoes
it has to be a one-word two-word answer
depends on your audience I think it's a
it's a tough question I think you should
have a have a point of view and you
should stay within that point of view
and don't put up things that fall
outside of that and also don't put up
things that were you're clearly just
trying to get some free shoes or you
know something to that end I think those
are you know those are my five things
and what Lauren said and everybody knows
that your coffee guy makes really good
foam art so there's no need for that on
the internet see that's perfect
no black and white pictures of
celebrities because sean has completely
counted yeah you can't mess corner that
whole market so don't do that [ __ ]
contracts with Getty I mean it's what
Michael said it's authenticity anything
that's not authentic is not cool plus
also there's a it gets to a certain
point sorry to keep blabbering but it
also gets um a certain point of where
you need to trust yourself and you trust
your I need to trust your vision and if
you're questioning putting something up
on your site or in any aspect of your
work and you're questioning it there's
probably a reason you're questioning it
and you should just stick with what your
gut tells you to do I mean that's like
basically the answer that you're looking
for right it's like if you have a
feeling like oh maybe I shouldn't put
this up then you probably shouldn't put
it up right like I think that's the key
so you have to stick stay in your lane
stay with your perspective and your
point of view and don't compromise that
right but obviously everybody has to eat
so you have to find again it goes back
to the balance right you just don't want
to put something up like you know if
you're if you're a hardcore Rick Owens
fan and your site's been dedicated to
Rick Owens been all of a sudden you're
like oh [ __ ] American heritage American
work where throw that up on there then
people are gonna notice like oh that's
completely off-base of what you've been
trying to say so it's like I think it's
just yeah find the balance and you gotta
just like like I said if you feel like
there's a hesitation on your part don't
put it up thank you guys
you